O
garçon de la rivière
chaleur frissonnante
tatouage de dragon sur le bras
short ouvert dans l'espace du cœur
aujourd'hui même devant j'aime le vert
acte de garçon
tension fluctuante de la rivière
je chante à Dieu
Protéger
la disponibilité
bonjour sois ici
Salut
[Musique]
tout ce dont je rêverai
ET là
partout
Vagues bleues des mers
quand je te vois je souhaite mon dieu quoi de neuf
[Musique]
la chaleur qui te fait frissonner
Prends cette chanson comme un baiser
Garçon de Rio
chaleur frissonnante
tatouage de dragon sur le bras
short à corps ouvert heart space
de haut en bas j'aime le vert
garçon a battu oncle
tension fluctuante de Rio je chante pour
Dieu
te protéger
ET là
et Avai est
salut a tous je reve
[Musique]
tous les endroits
Vagues bleues des mers
quand je te vois je souhaite ton souhait
garçon de la rivière
chaleur frissonnante
[Musique]
Prends cette chanson comme un
baiser
[Musique]
Prends cette chanson comme un baiser
ET là
[Musique]